he used to see hundreds of them
but today syed asha needs to be patient
if he wants to catch a glimpse of a
single
ganges dolphin
due to climate change and other factors
our
important viewers by our dolphin leaves
or almost a situated important areas and
so they um
migrated in here india and they became
endangered and people are responsible
dams and locks have rested as much water
as possible from the land
cutting off the natural paths of
dolphins and fish
nowadays the wetlands no longer live up
to their name
the land is dried up and the fish are
gone
for people in the popnar region it's a
disaster hundreds of them are digging up
this dried-up river branch to earn some
extra cash
sayad azir explains that the scheme is
part of an environmental project
to restore 34 wetlands species certain
species reappeared
after their excavation those disappeared
before
after the excavation they will come
again they will breed again
and biodiversity will be increased in
such a way but to make it work the
fishermen need to take an active role
it's up to them to conserve the stock of
fish
but for ram charan halder the small
amount he does catch
is barely enough to live on
the fish have disappeared and we're in
despair there's no longer any connection
to the rivers
one of the biggest challenges facing
project coordinator otilia mosofa from
the german association of international
cooperation
is assessing whether people can actually
afford to take part in this scheme
um a challenge
because there are poor people here who
really rely on these resources to
survive
and at that point it's a question of
whether or not you can afford to do
without the final
20 30 of your catch
the fishermen know that the future of
their livelihoods is at stake
fishing in protected areas is strictly
forbidden it's the only way to attract
endangered species back here to spawn
three protected areas have been reserved
for the few remaining ganges dolphins
for zayad azer it's an important first
step
sometimes some people try to harvest it
but fishers protect them
they're trying to conserve in this area
you